so coca-cola those healthy people who
just want to make you healthier they are
pushing health on us I just said health
18 times there so they're doing a new
branding thing in the US and in the UK
with print ads and commercials and all
this stuff so this is some of the video
that they're shown in the UK right now
with anyone
look about healthy people making healthy
choices granddad died of diabetes right
after that was shot by the way grandpa
died I think Emma's dead grandpa I'm
drinking a cold type 1 and type 2
there's a lot of shutter to put to that
okay we've talked about this a lot of
the show do you know before we get to
the rest of this stuff that they're not
even putting sugar in our coke in
America anyway yeah my what we have high
fructose corn soup you want wall
fructose Squatch sugar I want Mexico and
Maggie colleague about it sugar is too
expensive for them to put in our so they
get it in Mexico but we can't get sugar
because we're drinking corn we're
actually drinking corn anyway so they're
also releasing all this other
information to show you how good all
this stuff is you better be telling us
all these years but now they're they're
good guys so they put out this this
press release I like this one the new
coca-cola advert shows that the
lifestyle enjoyed by our grandparents
moving more eating well taking it easy
can be beneficial we're committed to
using our advertising to raise awareness
of importance of energy balance and
helping people to make informed choices
we believe it is just one of the ways we
can help make more people aware of the
need for a balanced diet and active
healthy lifestyle I really don't know
what what are they talking about like
grandpa that font by the way that was
not their finery about it yeah can I
inform you of two things about coke that
might counteract what they just said one
you know they put a chemical in
coca-cola that keeps you from vomiting
because there's so much sugar in a coke
that it would make you throw up here
comes the 911 truthers be I think that
we should all just touches that chemical
that you're you're lying about anti epic
at I don't know yeah yeah but thank you
but also if you can clean your car
battery with it don't drink it i think
you know that's something that we can
teach our job is so yeah well first of
all teaching children to not drink
anything off of a battery okay so what's
and know this whole thing I I know
friends of mine and they sent me these
things on Facebook sorry which I don't
go to any more but it's like if you
drink one coke here's what happens it
goes into your intestine it in flames
your
bladder and your chance of dying no
that's not the problem the problem with
that campaign is Cook has great
commercials over the years we're not
going to be healthy from coke we enjoy a
nice soda don't try and tell me it's an
energy thing just say look how enjoy it
okay I completely agree why don't they
just double down on you've been drinking
this stuff put out all their still here
we're still here like why are they even
pretending is it even necessary to
Americans even care whether they're
getting fat and obese and dying of all
they say that's a whole as topic for
another day but I don't I am anti the
whole obesity thing I think it's the
last group of people that we can pick on
there's no science based on any of these
things that people think I believe me
people wave with the way they wave the
way their grandfather best that's
different thing so you don't think
people are getting fat I I don't presume
oviya well that will course they're the
same stock footage of people heavy
people walking around as the third it's
it isn't billions of dollars in diet fad
things so I don't know that it causes
all those things but I don't know why
they first of all our coke sales down
well cokes say again well partly soda
sales in general or down and but now you
know there's things like in New York
City where they wanted to ban big sodas
so the other thing that they're using is
aspartame and aspartame okay so
aspartame is the calorie-free sweetener
that was invented in like nineteen
seventy-two it has something to do with
Donald Rumsfeld's family did you know
that was like pushed through the FDA
spiracy ferret that must be true that he
was uh involved in the ocean I think he
was in that unit back right here
bluemoon anyway they've released a
statement in defending their use of
aspartame our use of high quality low
and no-calorie sweeteners including
aspartame allows us to give people great
tasting options they can feel good about
time and again these low and no-calorie
sweeteners have shown to be safe
high-quality alternatives to sugar in
fact the safety of aspartame is
supported by more than 200 studies over
the last 40 years I mean the fact that
they said high-quality twice in one
short statement seems weird to me
there's some crazy things about
aspartame so you know people get all
kinds of crazy symptoms from dizziness
to memory loss seizures blinding
headaches and even full blindness so
should we be more against the
the stuff that's going to keep us thin
and kill us or the stuff that's going to
but they don't even thinking keep you
thin Hey look at look it's adam and
stevia not Adam and aspartame all right
go with stevia it's natural you're a big
fan of a wreath rittal yeah go with
those there's good nap there's good
natural PB is insanely expensive if you
how much I little thing is stevia it's
like at trader joe's it's like 12 bucks
drinks that are made you want to go with
a zero calorie drink they have drinks
that are made that are very tasty I have
a visa years world here's my completely
flip flop on you yeah if I could have
Diet Coke given to me intravenously I
would be the first one to sign up I love
it I need it I gotta have it I think
aspartame I there's a lot of a
conspiracy theories but I do believe
that there's enough weirdness about
around people drinking aspartame yeah I
would stop it if I were you and I'll
write you a prescription